وانسكبوا في جرن احزاني اتشبه بالافق
واصعب الى ذروه رغباتي ادونيس في جده اخر
محطات جولته السعوديه الشاعر والمفكر
الشهير شارك السعوديين احتفاءهم بعام
الشعر العربي 2023
بامسيه شهدت حضورا جماهريا كبيرا حينما
قدم الى السعوديه احنا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اردنا من خلال هذا الحضور وهذه
الزياره احداث حراك ثقافي مناقشات امسيات
شعريه نلتقي ببقامه علميه وشعريه وادبيه
معروفه وراقيه وقدمت بالثقافه العربيه شيء
الكثير
ايتها الضاد الضاد يا لغه يا بيتي قصائد
وحكايا من الشعر العربي زين بها ادونيس
امسيته في جده فضلا عن معزوفات غنائيه
شعريه للشاعر الراحل الامير عبد الله
الفيصل ضمن جولات ادبيه تقيمها اكاديميه
الشعر العربي هذا العام ما بعد ادونيس هو
مشروع سعودي
ثقافي ادبي شعري
يرتبط
بالمكان التاريخيه التي تنتمي او الارث
التاريخي الذي انتمي لهذه الارض ارض
الجزيره العربيه كيف
اجنحه
التي تنتحب في اقفاص اللغه حراك ادبي
ثقافي تعيشه السعوديه هذه السنوات
واستقطاب لابرز الادباء والمثقفين حراك
وقوده التفاعل والاهتمام الكبير من جميع
الاوساط من جده اسامه القاسم العربيه